[Musique]
dans l'Ouest canadien les ours grizzly
sont liés à une avancée scientifique
simple en apparence mais très efficace
pour dénombrer les animaux qui se
trouvent sur un territoire donné ce sont
des informations primordiales pour
comprendre l'état de santé d'une
population surtout quand on sait que le
nombre d'ours grizzly a subi de grandes
fluctuations
[Musique]
dans les montagnes de l'Ouest il est le
maître des forêts
la présence de Grizzly est synonyme de
milieu sauvage une image forte de nature
à l'état brute
mais quand cette nature sauvage les de
moins en moins vous avez du vélo de
montagne de lilisky et tout le reste
l'exploitation forestière l'aménagement
de rude
maintenant on a l'église les plus en
plus près de là où il vit et les gens
pour en arriver à une cohabitation
viable l'humain nous devons partager le
territoire
[Musique]
de la Colombie-Britannique a une mission
bien unique
compter la population d'ours grizzly
dans le secteur
illisant sur
le chaque année pour mesurer la
reproduction
l'étude était ici depuis
1978 à mon avis c'est le plus long étude
sur les ours au Canada
on estime qu'il est à peu près sombre
que je l'ai dans le Valais c'est
sûrement en population en santé c'est à
peu près trois fois plus grand que la
population pendant les années 70
malgré sa force légendaire le Grizzly a
beaucoup souffert il y a quelques
siècles le Grizzly existait partout dans
l'ouest du continent de l'Alaska
jusqu'au fleuve Mississippi en passant
par la Californie il existe même au
Mexique mais la chasse à l'ours
excessive et les activités humaines ont
eu raison d'une large part de son aire
de répartition
il avait pas de limite de la chasse ils
étaient persuculés
par les les fermiers les Rangers et ils
avaient aucun protection vraiment ou
très peu de protection
[Musique]
aujourd'hui le Grizzly se trouve
majoritairement dans les zones
montagneuses de l'Alberta de la
Colombie-Britannique du Yukon et de
l'Alaska ainsi que dans certains
endroits protégés très ciblés aux
États-Unis dans le nord du Montana ou au
parc Yellowstone
pour arriver à compter de façon précise
les fluctuations d'une population de
Grizzly dans un secteur
utilise une technique bien simple
installée du fil barbelé autour des
arbres
les jours s'ils sentent les arbres pour
deux
raisons
pour marquer un territoire c'est plutôt
les femelles et les ours jaune
et aussi et il préfère des arbres qui
peuvent
griffer ils adorent l'odeur de le
résine et c'est là qui commence le
désir à chanter et finalement quand il
frotte l'arbre les
adultes ils se mettent comme ça avec la
tête en eau et donc il faut tout leur
dos et la tête
donc là souvent on a des échantillons un
peu partout parce qu'il faut que les
épaules la tête les oreilles le dos les
fesses des fois un peu j'étais un peu le
ramdam quoi et nous on veut les
échantillon de tous les arbres qui
vivent sur le région d'études
biologiste Michael rocker a développé
cette technique de collecte
d'échantillons de Grizzly il y a
maintenant plus de 25 ans
dans une touffe de poils nous obtenons
de l'ADN et avec cette ADN nous pouvons
générer une empreinte ADN pour chaque
course
[Musique]
l'analyse des poils de Grizzly se fait
en laboratoire analson dans le centre
sud de la Colombie Britannique
ce laboratoire contient une importante
collection d'ADN de Grizzly de partout
dans l'ouest du pays et d'ours brun
d'ailleurs dans le monde
dans ce laboratoire il y a probablement
des poils de tous les ours qui ont été
échantillonnés en Colombie-Britannique
depuis 1995 c'est plusieurs milliers
d'échantillons sur une période de plus
de 25 ans
cela nous permet d'examiner les
déplacements la connectivité la
fragmentation des populations et aussi
d'établir des liens de parenté génétique
[Musique]
lorsque vous joignez les données d’adn
aux données des colis télémétriques
alors là tout devient clair nous pouvons
comprendre pourquoi il se déplace
quelles habitats ils utilisent nous
avons alors une bonne idée de toutes les
dynamiques qui les affectent ainsi que
leur démographie
[Musique]
toutes ces données permettent d'estimer
qu'à l'heure actuelle en
Colombie-Britannique il y aurait environ
15000 grizzly l'état de leur population
n'est toutefois pas le même partout
de la province c'est plus sauvage la
population d'ours est en très bonne
santé mais ce n'est pas le cas dans le
Sud où il y a beaucoup de chevauchement
avec les activités humaines
l'action combiné du trafic automobile et
de la présence humaine à fragmenter les
populations parfois ont de très petits
groupes certains endroits les ours sont
menacés
animales est un sérieux enjeu pour
qu'une population soit considérée en
bonne santé les animaux doivent avoir
une base génétique diversifiée pour ce
faire ils doivent être en mesure de se
déplacer dans le territoire
le mouvement c'est nécessaire dans le
nature mais on veut que il est un peu de
mouvement entre les populations pour que
les génétiques dans un population ne
baisse la défense de génétique ne baisse
pas trop dans un individuel population
peuvent circuler sur 500 2000 voir 5000
km². c'est mal en se reproduisant
propage leurs gènes
les
ours sont à peu près tous génétiquement
identiques il existe une sous-espèce sur
l'île kodiaque au large de l'Alaska qui
est isolé depuis des milliers et des
milliers d'années
génétique le vrai problème est
démographique par exemple tout près de
Nelson nous avons une population isolée
d'environ 50 ours cela signifie que de
ce nombre il y a environ une douzaine de
femelles adultes une année il y a un
excès de mortalité pour toutes sortes de
raisons alors on peut descendre jusqu'à
trois ou quatre femelles reproductrices
et c'est tout comme il n'y a pas de
mouvement de population alors c'est un
gros problème pour assurer un avenir à
cette population
[Musique]
nos routes nos villes et nos activités
divisent donc le territoire
anelson comme partout tout ce que nous
faisons prend de plus en plus d'espace
[Musique]
la région de Nelson est l'une des
premières à avoir développé le vélo de
montagne l'endroit est reconnu pour ses
pistes difficiles et donc ça attire
beaucoup de touristes
passionnée de vélos de montagne
biologiste elle pratique chaque jour son
sport mais avec une attention toute
particulière à l'aide de caméra elle
étudie l'impact du passage de vélo en
forêt sur les populations d'ours
[Musique]
in
dans ce projet j'essaie de mesurer des
ondes différentes là où il y a peu voire
aucun cycliste et puis je vais comparer
cela au Sentier de vélo de montagne très
utilisé nous voulons voir si les animaux
ou les ours utilisent ces secteurs
différemment en fonction de la présence
humaine
les données recueillies par Michel
Mettet la lune seront ensuite jumelés
aux échantillons d’adn récoltés dans le
secteur bien connaître l'évolution de la
population d'ours ici et l'impact d'une
activité comme le vélo de montagne
permettra donc une meilleure protection
de l'animal
plus nous rencontrons des ours plus ils
s'habituent à nous et plus ils perdent
leur peur naturelle cela affecte leur
taux de survie car ils sont plus
susceptibles d'entrer en conflit avec
nous le résultat est souvent la mort
surtout pour les oursons
les loisirs individuels n'ont
probablement pas beaucoup d'impact et
quand vous multipliez par milliers le
nombre d'usagers alors là il y en a
certainement d'ailleurs
j'aimerais bien documenter cet impact de
cette manière nous pourrions prendre de
meilleures décisions quant aux endroits
ou aménagés et ne pas aménager des
sentiers
le Grizzly nous offre une image
saisissante et indélébile de la nature
sauvage pour sa santé et notre sécurité
il doit rester sauvage et surtout loin
de nous
depuis les dernières décennies les
recherches les mesures de protection ou
l'implantation de corridor de
connectivité entre deux territoires ont
permis de faire des gains à plusieurs
endroits
dans les années 70 on a arrêté de tuer
les grizzly
aucun raison et donc
lentement ils ont repris certaines coins
qui étaient abandonnés par les grizzly
et c'est un bon Nivelle parce que c'est
c'est un succès story pour la
consommation
malgré les pas en avant de nombreux
vents de face continuent de souffler
changement climatique offre de
nourriture ou encore et toujours une
cohabitation difficile avec nous le job
le travail n'est pas terminé il y a
encore des endroits où nous tuons trop
d'ours c'est un paradoxe car plus nous
améliorons l'habitat des ours plus la
population du main augmente
font partie de tout un écosystème il
joue un rôle dans cette mosaïque
écologique dans cette chaîne alimentaire
c'est important de les protéger et de
leur assurer une juste place
[Musique]